in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen."
The reading from the Sinaxadion, for June 25th, on which we commemorate the Holy New
martyr, George of Atalia, born of an affluent and devout family in Atalia, in Asia Minor,
Pamphilia, St. George was captured while still a child by the Aga of the region, who converted
him to Islam, and after having kept him in his service for several years, married him to
his own daughter.
His weeping parents had sought him everywhere, and when they learned that he was in the
Aga's service, and that he had apostatized, they suggested to a devout woman called Maria,
who was also in the service in the palace, that she remained George of his origins, and
of how his parents were suffering at the loss of his soul.
These words, passed on by Maria, fell on the young man's heart, like seed on fertile ground,
and he decided to escape as soon as possible.
Having obtained his master's permission to undertake a pilgrimage to Mecca, he went to find Maria
in Jerusalem, and after having made his confession, venerated all the holy places with tears.
After two years, Maria, who had been taking care of him, like a mother, advised him to join
some pilgrims who had come from Carinea in Asia Minor, and to go and settle in that hospitable
town where Christians and Turks lived on good terms.
He therefore settled there, following the profession of coffee-seller, and married a young
Christian called Helena.
The Greek Revolution, having broken out in 1821, this region suffered from punitive expeditions
by the Ottoman army.
One day, the arrival of the Pasha of Atalia, George's former master at the head of a troop
of fierce warriors was announced.
He was heading for Heos, which he had decided to destroy with fire and blood.
When Maria and Helena advised George to go and hide, he replied that he had nothing to fear,
but that on the contrary, he would greatly profit from this situation.
When the Pasha arrived, George, who was still working as a groom, helped him to dismount.
A few moments later, looking through the window, the Pasha realized that the groom who was taking
his mount to the stable, was none other than his son-in-law.
He sent for him and asked him why he had disappeared.
The saint replied,
You're wrong.
I am not Mechmed, but George.
And it is as a Christian that I shall die.
Seized with fury, the Pasha ordered that he be put in prison after being thrashed.
The officer, having failed in his attempt to make him submit, he had him shut in a cell,
his feet held in a heavy wooden vice.
A priest called George, being told of these events, advised the leading men to imprison
two Christians under the pretext of debt, so that he could, through them, take holy communion
to the martyr.
During this time, the torturers placed a burning copper vessel on his head, and then poured
boiling oil over his body.
As the saint endured these sufferings, giving glory to God, the Pasha decided to make an
end, and hang him as a malefactor.
That same evening, the priest, George, succeeded in sending him holy communion, concealed in
some grapes.
Full of joy the saint spent the whole night in prayer, asking God to help him in his last contest.
On the morning of Saturday the 25th of June, in 1823, he was taken to the central town square,
where a gallows had been erected.
As soon as the rope around his neck tightened, he cried out, remember me, O Lord, and turning
his eyes to the east gave up his spirit.
His body was left hanging for three days, guarded by Turkish soldiers, who each night saw
a light surrounding it and a priest appearing beside it to sense it.
The judge when informed ordered that it be taken down and cast into deep sea, after having
been dragged to the port.
As the saint's body floated and bumped against the keel of a Greek ship under an Austrian
flag, the captain retrieved it and having recognized it took it to Russia, where it was venerated
by the Christian people.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and
save us.